noi siamo fortunati
viviamo nel momento storico
grande innovazione tecnologica e ogni
giorno facciamo nuove scoperte
invenzioni che semplificano la nostra
vita risolvere i nostri problemi e ci
danno nuove e incredibili possibilità ma
le preoccupazioni non sono finite se da
una parte possiamo inviare messaggi foto
video documenti e telefonare a tutto il
mondo dall'altra possiamo essere spiati
in qualsiasi momento se da un lato
possiamo prendere un aereo e volare in
qualsiasi angolo del pianeta
dall'altro rabbrividiamo di fronte alla
distruzione causata da un bombardamento
aereo
abbiamo un farmaco pronto per quasi
tutte le malattie ma siamo terrorizzati
all'idea delle armi batteriologiche
infatti insieme a questo potere insieme
a questo grande potere di fare nuove
cose nessuno già ad un libretto di
istruzioni che ci dica come utilizzarlo
oggi voglio scrivere con voi la prima
pagina di questo libretto di istruzioni
la prima pagina del manuale utente della
tecnologia ma prima voglio raccontarvi
una storia
immaginate di aver studiato le grandi
teorie scientifiche del passato
immaginate di avere osservato un
universo e di aver avuto grandi idee
immaginate di avere organizzato queste
idee non teoria scientifica coerente che
riesca a spiegare la storia
dell'universo il suo inizio la sua
evoluzione che riesca a darvi
addirittura qualche suggerimento sul
futuro e ora immaginate di essere
bloccati nel vostro corpo intrappolati
nel vostro corpo
immaginate la frustrazione e non poter
utilizzare nella vostra voce nelle
vostre mani per dire o scrivere questa
grande teoria che esiste solo nella
vostra mente questa non è una storia
inventata questa era la vera situazione
e stephen hawking il celebre astrofisico
che con il suo lavoro allargato la
conoscenza umana sull'universo ma
stephen hawking ha fatto qualcosa di
ancora più importante e stephen hawking
con la sua serie a rotelle con la sua
voce sintetizzata dimostrato che la
tecnologia può e deve essere utilizzata
per dare indipendenza a tutte le persone
con disabilità la tecnologia ha permesso
a un giovane ragazzo qui erano stati
dati dai 25 anni di vita
di ottenere la cattedra di matematica
che era stata essa newton la tecnologia
permesso stephen hawking di essere uno
dei più grandi divulgatori scientifici
nel nostro tempo nonostante fosse
impossibilitato a muoversi ea parlare
utilizzando le sue stesse parole sono
stato fortunato a perdere la voce
all'inizio dell'era dei personal
computer
la tecnologia che si sta sviluppando
oggi per i disabili apre la strada per
abbattere le barriere di comunicazione
che c'erano una volta questo io scrivere
oggi con voi sulla prima pagina del
manuale utente della tecnologia
il primo scopo della tecnologia e
aiutare le persone con più difficoltà
la tecnologia sicuramente utilizzata
bene senza nessun dubbio quando è a
sostegno ea supporto delle persone con
disabilità sono arrivato a questa
convinzione grazie alcune esperienze
personali infatti da tempo il nostro
gruppo di ricerca all'università di
camerino è al lavoro per sviluppare
prodotti che siano sostegno delle
persone con disabilità
tutto è cominciato cinque anni fa quando
da studente ho preso parte per la prima
volta un gruppo di ricerca questo gruppo
questo progetto di ricerca era portato
avanti da alcune aziende italiane aveva
come scopo come obiettivo lo sviluppo di
un esoscheletro per disabili grazie a
questo scheletro le persone che usano
una sedia a rotelle possono alzarsi da
sole e muoversi e camminare anche in
quei luoghi e presentano barriere
architettoniche
quando arriva il progetto era già in
fase avanzata il proprietario della
principale azienda coinvolta in progetto
mi raccontò il primo test della prima
sperimentazione che avevano condotto con
un ragazzo che usava la sedia a rotelle
a causa di un incidente stradale
il testo è andato benissimo
per la prima volta dopo anni questo
ragazzo da solo si è alzato e ha
camminato per alcuni metri
come potete immaginare nel laboratorio
erano tutti felicissimi subito gli
chiesero come fosse tornare nuovo in
piedi che sensazioni si provasse a
utilizzare la sua scheletro
quello che solitamente non riusciamo mai
a pensare la risposta sono felice sono
felice perché finalmente posso parlarti
guardandoti negli occhi stando la tua
stessa altezza questa storia ci fa
capire un errore che commettiamo spesso
ovvero che pensiamo di sapere quali
siano i reali problemi le necessità e le
speranze delle altre persone quando
troppo spesso invece non ne sappiamo
nulla
per questo non solo la tecnologia deve
aiutare aiutare le persone con
disabilità è vero anche il contrario le
persone con disabilità devono essere
ascoltate rese partecipi nello sviluppo
della tecnologia le persone con
disabilità devono essere messe in
condizione di sviluppare la tecnologia
che li potrà aiutare perché solo loro
sanno realmente di cosa hanno bisogno
prima di scrivere la prossima regola la
prossima pagina il nostro ma non
all'utente voglio mostrarvi una cosa
questo è il progetto su cui al momento
sta lavorando il nostro gruppo di
ricerca
il sono ciao a tutti sono talking heads
il mio scopo voce il mio voce scopo è
non dare voce a chi voce non ha
talking heads stato pensato per le
persone sorde che solitamente utilizzano
la lingua dei segni per comunicare
tuttavia solo una piccola parte degli
utenti conoscere la lingua dei segni e
per questo le persone sorde hanno
difficoltà di comunicazione nella vita
quotidiana
pensiamo che con talking heads
le persone sorde potranno utilizzare
loro segni per comunicare con tutti ma
sorprendentemente in questi ultimi mesi
ci stiamo accorgendo che forse talkie
niente potrà aiutare molte più persone
infatti nonostante stessimo lavorando da
alcuni anni a questo progetto non chiamo
in fondo ea pieno capito le reali
potenzialità della nostra tecnologia
il primo segnale è stata questa mail che
ho ricevuto alcuni mesi fa buongiorno
dario mi chiamo papà di marco utilizza
un nome casuale per cui tv privacy
autistico con l'ispra sia severa che ne
limita fortemente il linguaggio
rendendolo praticamente inesistente
grazie al vostro segnale lavoro questa
sua lacuna potrebbe essere colmata
sarei felice se potesse assistere o
meglio ancora scelto come soggetto per
la prossima sperimentazione questa mail
e ci stava dicendo che la nostra
tecnologia può forse aiutare tutti
coloro che hanno difficoltà nel
linguaggio parlato come ad esempio
alcune persone affette da autismo
colpite da ictus da altre malattie
debilitanti
oggi marco il primo bambino che noiosa
torchi nens
ma il progetto ancora in via e
sperimentazione ma lui la sua famiglia e
tutti noi siamo convinti che con qualche
sviluppo in più potremo migliorare di
molto la sua comunicazione
questa storia ci dà anche un altro
spunto per il nostro manuale utente
questa storia dimostra che non sempre è
necessario creare una nuova tecnologia
per risolvere un problema
molte delle tecnologie già esistenti
devono essere riviste utilizzate per
aiutare le persone con disabilità sono
convinto che la tecnologia e sarà uno
strumento necessario per dare alle
persone con disabilità molte possibilità
ma al momento non hanno la tecnologia i
permetterà di avere più controllo sulle
loro vite di interagire più facilmente
con tutti e così di partecipare e
contribuire maggiormente a casa a scuola
e nel lavoro
la tecnologia gli permetterà di avere di
cogliere tutte quelle occasioni che
troppo spesso chi non è disabilitata per
scontato infatti la disabilità non è una
prigione
la prigione è una è la mancanza di una
tecnologia necessaria per affrontare la
disabilità grazie a tutti